what I did was I reached out to every
single person that was in the network I
pretended they were a client of mine so
I offered every single person to go
review all of their sales scripts review
their sales processes and I did it like
it was an actual project that I got paid
for and so I'd hop on the phone and I
would have pages of notes how I'd
rewrite everything and they were like
whoa dude what you want them to say is
this is too much and so what happens is
you basically plug into everyone else's
Network and skills by giving first and I
had hopped on with plenty of others who
have never given me anything back comma
and that's okay most entrepreneurs we
say we want to make an impact and help
people it's like well that's what that
looks like if you give something to
someone and they don't give anything
back then it means you just gave to
someone that's it great yeah
congratulations and if you talk about
personal brand wouldn't that be the
brand that you'd want to build anyways
yes